depuis plus d'une semaine les craintes
d'une troisième vague semble se
concrétiser pour pays certaines
provinces comme l'ontario l'ont déjà
déclaré pour d'autres c'est une
éventualité à laquelle on se prépare
mais si une troisième vague peut sembler
inévitable il reste encore beaucoup
d'incertitudes quant à l'ampleur qu'elle
pourrait prendre et pour plusieurs
épidémiologistes les gestes qu'on va
poser au cours des prochaines semaines
seront déterminants pour l'évolution de
la pandémie durant la prochaine année
pourquoi fait-on déjà face à une
troisième vague
s'il sait pas c'est si peu de temps
entre la deuxième et la troisième vague
cet accord est varié ces derniers sont
entre 1,4 et 1,8 fois plus transmissible
que les virus auquel on faisait face
lors des deux premières vagues cette
vitesse de propagation ici différentes
que pour certains chercheurs ont fait
maintenant face à deux pandémies une
première avec les anciens variant -
transmissibles et une seconde avec les
variants d'intérêt qui se propage
beaucoup plus facilement si on regarde
les données en provenance de l'ontario
par exemple on peut voir deux courbes
différentes une première avec les
anciens va rien le nombre de cas baisse
progressivement et une seconde fait des
nouveaux variants d'intérêts où le
nombre de cas augmente progressivement
les variants d'intérêt représente
maintenant plus de 50 % des nouveaux cas
en ontario et leur nombre augmente dans
plusieurs autres provinces
cette vague est elle différente des deux
précédentes avec les variantes d'un côté
et les vaccins de l'autre plusieurs
épidémiologistes s'entendent pour dire
que la troisième vague n'évoluera pas de
la même manière que les précédentes
d'abord parce que le virus commence à
toucher les tranches d'âge différentes
ça peut s'expliquer par le succès de la
campagne de vaccination chez les plus de
70 ans chez qui les vaccins ont réduit
le nombre de cas et le nombre
d'hospitalisations mais aussi parce
qu'on voit de plus en plus de cas graves
chez les patients plus jeunes entre 30
et 60 ans qui n'ont pas été vaccinés
cette hausse peut s'expliquer par la
plus grande contagiosité mais aussi par
les symptômes plus sévères qu'entraînent
les nouveaux variants ensuite la
vaccination pourrait
zouhir l'ampleur de la troisième vague
mais seulement 6 à 7 personnes prennent
le vaccin et si on lui laisse aussi le
temps d'agir ce qui prend au minimum
deux semaines après avoir reçu la
première dose
c'est pour ces raisons que dans les
régions qui sont déjà touchés par la
troisième vague comme le grand toronto
par exemple aider les experts
considèrent que le seul moyen pour les
vaccins de rattraper les variants sait
si on remet en place des mesures plus
sévères
pendant encore quelques semaines pour ce
qui est des régions qui n'ont pas encore
été touchées c'est très important de
continuer de suivre les mesures
sanitaires pour retarder l'arrivée de la
troisième vague est ici donner le plus
de temps possible à la campagne de
vaccination
à quoi peut-on s'attendre pour 2021
prévoir l'évolution de la pandémie
devait 19 est un travail incroyablement
complexe la variabilité des symptômes la
multiplication des variantes
le taux de vaccination qui varient
beaucoup d'une à travers les différents
segments de la population
tous se rend le travail des
modélisateurs très compliqué mais
certains moments clés au cours de
l'année pourrait nous indiquer les
tendances à venir
l'un d'eux l automne prochain quand une
bonne part de la population va rentrer à
l'intérieur à cause des températures qui
diminue ce qui augmente les risques de
transmission de la maladie en même temps
à l'automne 2021
une bonne part la population devrait
avoir reçu le vaccin contre la kfw 19
cette période sera donc le premier vrai
test de l'immunité qui nous est conférée
par les vaccins à ce moment là beaucoup
de variables encore inconnues vont
entrer en jeu
est ce qu'une bonne part de la
population va avoir accepté le vaccin
quelle est la durite de l'immunité que
ces vaccins nous offre est-ce qu'on va
rien résistants ont refait son
apparition
la réponse à toutes ces questions qu'on
va voir à l'automne prochain sera
déterminante pour savoir qu'est ce qui
nous attend en 2022
que va devenir la coved 19 ce qui est
certain c'est que la kfw 19 à continuer
la partie nos vies pour le reste de
l'année et que tant que la population
sera pas vacciner les masques et la
distanciation sociales vont rester les
outils essentiels
mais pour ce qui est de la fin de la
pandémie elle-même tout reste incertain
peut-être que la vaccination offert de
la coved 19 un virus beaucoup plus rares
comme celui de la rougeole ou peut-être
qu'à force de muter la kfw 19 autres
progressivement devenir un virus
beaucoup moins graves comme un rhume par
exemple mais tout ça va dépendre de
plusieurs éléments
certains jeux sur lesquels on n'a pas de
contrôle comme l'évolution du virus
d'autres comme l'efficacité des vaccins
et le progrès de la science qui vient
avec
mais surtout ça va dépendre des efforts
qu'on veut mettre au cours de la
prochaine année
pour consulter toutes les capsules où on
répond à vos questions
rendez vous sur le site de radio canada